welcome back for another exciting day of
boot camp today I figured we'll have a
counterpoint from yesterday I will try
to do everything at the white board
really just want to go through where is
yesterday we tried to cover an entire
semesters worth of material in an hour
and a half today I would like to cover a
lectures worth of material in an hour
and a half so that's much more
reasonable and kind of point out whereas
yesterday was really all about what week
the current state of what we know
algorithms can do on large data sets
well today I want to point out is look
what what can we prove about data sets
using techniques from optimizations and
in particular we're gonna prove one
theorem and use that to kind of
highlight a lot of the kind of that kind
of core techniques and tools that people
use commonly in this area and it cut
will lead into a some of the more
general advanced techniques that Martin
will talk about in the next two lectures
so hopefully this get will get
acclimated before we cut dive into all
of high dimensional statistics so what
we want to prove is one theorem today
just the following so let X 0 and our n
be a sparse vector
by that I mean all but s of the
components are non zero r r0 sorry other
way around
nausea will be worse let a be a M by n
random matrix with either squeaky
markers I apologize a IJ sampled from a
normal distribution with variance 1 over
m ok so just a standard Gaussian random
matrix then and we also have that M is
greater than or equal to 1 plus epsilon
times s 2 to s log n plus s plus 1 I
hate that plus 1 but it really just
doesn't make the formulas look nicer
anyway so leave his head plus 1 ok then
X 0 is the unique optimal solution of
with probability and at least one - -
and - the - I apologize for this one -
okay so now I'm in the way I'll just end
it stand aside from the theorem this is
what we'd like to prove I think we
should be able to do this in an hour and
a half almost out in an almost
elementary fashion so this is kind of
the standard results that you might see
in compressed sensing in some sense this
is the most fundamental or not
fundamental but I'll let the most
primitive compressed sensing result that
you might prove the idea is this we're
interested in finding a sparse vector
from a a matrix and what we could think
about here is that every row of this
matrix is providing some information
about the vector X X is sparse we want
to say how many pieces of information do
we need to find X using some kind of
polynomial time algorithm okay so what
the album we're using is minimizing the
l1 norm which I hope everybody here kind
of had seen that that's what we do we
want sparse you want l1 yeah Robert go
ahead of you cause you mean you already
got into a suitable basis that is sparse
I'm assuming that X is sparse x0 is
sparse it's just in the standard basis
so it's just it's gonna have s non zeros
and zeros everywhere else we could do it
in a different basis if you'd like
because we're measuring with a Gaussian
random maker yeah so it doesn't care
what basis is Sparsit which is the nice
pack but I'm just gonna assume that we
know the basis is the standard basis and
the matrix we're measuring with is a
random matrix the entries are just
generated at iid from the Gaussian
distribution and what we want to prove
is how many rows does that matrix have
to have how many measurements do we have
to take before we can recover the vector
X 0 and recovering it using just a
linear programming so we want to just
have a linear programming a solution
return the answer ok
and the number of metrics we kinda need
is a 1 plus epsilon as we always this
makes it look like one of our standard
Theory results we have 1 plus epsilon
times 2 s log N and then that epsilon is
basically going to propagate into the
error probability okay this has got more
of these standard things we want we
would like to to understand and show
today this is not an optimal result we
could actually I think if we want to
make it optimal we would have actually
this is why have multiple hence the
optimal result would have this divided
by s log n over s would be what we'd
like to get we're not going to get that
today but to trade off to actually get a
suboptimal result what we're gonna do is
actually the this this proof will rely
only on convex geometry and duality
which is kind of using these
optimization tools and then the all need
to know the large deviations of
chi-squared random variables and that's
it no random matrix Theory really I mean
weird if somewhat random matrix theory
but we're not going to look at things
like what Joel Trump talked about on on
what was that Tuesday it seems like
forever ago but things that y'all talked
about on Tuesday we don't need anything
particularly fancy to prove this result
the only kind of result we need to know
and if we had two hours we could
actually prove that result from first
principles as well is what are the large
deviations of chi-squared random
variables quite have time to do
everything but we you know that's what
we want to go so questions about the
statement or work or where we'd like to
go or anything - n - the - it's an
exponent it's to end to the - that crud
so what can we say about this first
thing is that if s gets bigger that gets
this probability gets a bit higher so
the worst case is when the product 1 s
is 1 for whatever reason artifact of
some analysis the other thing is the
epsilon gets bigger this gets small
probability again gets closer to 1 has
the properties you want and I trade it
off having a nice looking bound for M
and or having ugly looking down for the
probability what can you do
but I think the key thing to note here
is that as n if n is huge if we're in a
high dimensional regime that's one even
if epsilon and and and s are small
all right any questions about the set up
it's crazy that's our standard problem
this is kind of a know just what lot
want to know very quickly that this
problem is like we were talking about
how to solve this yesterday we flipped
the role of the the the cost function in
the constraint I think we looked at
yesterday we put this down in the
constraint we put this up in the cost
function but you know morally this is
the simplest version this essentially
would be the case where we observe
properties of X 0 with no noise just
what I understand what happens in that
case in which case we could flip the
cost in the constraint that's a great
question and so why if I wanted to use a
method from yesterday to solve it I
would actually do it would slip these I
would do it one of two things I would
either flip these or I would actually
join this as a quadratic constraint to
this problem and for appropriately
chosen multiplier you can actually show
that they're equivalent we're not going
to do that today but yeah that would be
another way to solve it there are lots
of algorithms for actually there was I
mean props you know they're like four
thousand papers on just algorithms to
solve this this I'm not I'm not under
estimating the number I mean it's
ridiculous they're like four thousand
papers on solving this linear program
this is crazy
it might be more it's quite possibly
true it's quite possibly true I think
you guys you do have one of my favorite
ones that's got something right okay any
other questions about that set up so so
so here's the first question if we're
just looking at a problem like minimize
f of X subject to x equals B what does
it mean when does X star minimize this
function over this set or the state I
will say solve the optimization problem
when does the X star solve the
optimization problem so intuitively this
is a very city oh now I'm over there Wow
all right so to me this is actually a
fairly simple answer to when it's solve
it so basically what it was the feasible
set so the set of all X such that a X is
equal to B is the same as the set of X
star plus h where H lives in the null
space of a alright I'm a standard linear
algebra trick so X star is the solution
if f of X plus h is greater than or
equal to f of X yes for all H and the
null space of a
so I mean I'm again this is very doing
trivialities here but but it's kind of
getting us to where we would like to be
so if I if I define a set T to be the
set of all directions such that FX star
plus alpha D is greater than F at X star
for alpha for some alpha greater than
zero I'm sorry other way around less
than or equal to let's do it this way so
we want to say what are all the
directions that actually could make the
function smaller at X star we just want
to say when does T intersect didn't all
of a equal the set of zero so what we're
asking is when does a cone which has
some particular structure that's
associated with F so we have F and then
we're gonna have all these directions
and make this smaller T and then we're
gonna have the set of feasible
directions a the null space of a and we
just want to say when did these two
things intersect only at the at the
origin and that is every theoretical
paper on compressed sensing every reason
we're just we're doing is trying to
prove when does a Phi space intersect
the cone at the orange okay so there are
many ways to do that I think Martin is
going to discuss some notions from
statistics in terms of restricted eigen
value theory and there are ways to do
this we're really just kind of looking
at things that look very much like
minimizing its notions of eigen values
but instead of having the set of all the
things that we're allowed to to look at
in our Rayleigh potion we restrict that
set to be some kind of cone that's
called restricted aggregate theory I
would like to do something a little bit
more elementary than that and just look
at what's called the the sub
differential theory so you'll note that
the l1 norm is not differentiable
everywhere at zero in particular you
can't there's no gradient so we can't
but convex functions and especially non
non smooth convex functions have always
have something that looks like a
gradient associated with them at every
point and those are called sub gradients
so we say that G is a sub gradient of F
at X if F of Z is greater than or equal
to F at X plus G transpose X minus Z
minus X for all Z sub a sub gradient and
remember from yesterday one of the
definitions of convex smooth convex
functions a way to kind of characterize
them we're what we're ones where this
approximation where G was a gradient was
always below the function so this kind
of just generalizing that notion to some
other vector G you know so we say maybe
there's not just a gradient maybe
there's something else and we call that
a sub gradient so if I okay the one
problem without making slides is my
we're gonna you have to deal with my
terrible artwork here okay here we go
that's kind of pointy yeah sure
so that's a that's a function f quite
clearly convex you can just look at it
and a sub gradient at this point
there's one all right there's a
direction that's complete a hyperplane
that's completely below the curve and
touches at that point and then there
here's another one basically anything in
between also works right and so there's
more than one there's an infinite set of
sub grades there well here we go bear
with it
there you go now since I'm gradient
again yeah easier to do easier to do in
keynote the white board you know I can't
I guess the real point though is it's
much harder for me to fake that at this
point right the there's only one tangent
curve here and I would have a lot harder
term so so we we define something called
the sub differential it's just a set of
sub gradients
and moreover we're gonna so that the
this is called the sub differential and
D F at X is equal to the gray in of F if
F is differentiable so if I take the
cone of the sub differential I get the
polar cone to this we're not going to
talk about that this is something that
we're not gonna be able to talk about in
detail today because I didn't want us to
keep it elementary but they are very
closely related this essentially if I
take a element of the sub differential I
take its dot product with something in
this cone I get a negative number I [ __ ]
Eric there's another way to characterize
the sub differential okay so if it's
smooth then the sub differential is a
singleton if it's not smooth that might
have something else all right and so if
we did some examples so let's just we'll
be very will be very we'll just focus on
the one problem that we care about today
which is just the l1 norm so what do I
need to know I need to what is the sub
differential of the absolute value of x
okay so if let's see if you guys are
with me if X is greater than zero what
is what is this sub differential yes and
if X is less than zero
whoever said that you could say it again
- last good and then so the interesting
case is that x equals zero draw there's
my function we basically have anything
in between 1 and minus 1 sorry it's an
interval
if X is equal to zero so you have the
whole interval from minus 1 to 1 that's
here yeah sure no that's fine that's
fair that's better that's better guess
yes I'm happy to do that okay so that's
that that's that's that guy and they're
there they're really just two facts that
you want to know about submarines and
that really does almost everything all
the sub grading calculus that you need
kind of follow through from these two
fat well maybe three facts first one is
really simple is that if I take the sub
differential of a times F is just equal
to a times the sub differential addition
so if you scale the function you scale
the sub differential the second one is
that the sub differential of a sum is
the Minkowski sum so I always I don't
know if I have a better notation for
this yet but that's fine I'm just gonna
use this so and that I mean when Kowski
sum so what I really mean there is that
you're taking the sum but you haven't
take one element from every sub
differential right so you take one
element from every sub differential sum
them up that gives you an element of the
sub differential here
oh this isn't in Kowski sum and then
actually the one we're not gonna use
this today but this is really might as
well part of pass on me the most useful
fact about sub gradients is that the sub
differential of f of X well let's say so
let's say F is just the max over an
arbitrary collection of affine functions
so I take the max over an index set of
an arbitrary collection of affine
functions the sub differential is the
convex hull of all the AI where f of X
is equal to AI transpose X
so basically anything that achieves a
maximum goes it is one of the gradient
vectors and you didn't take their convex
hull and pretty much every every time
you need to calculate sub differential
you're just gonna use one of these three
rules and can tandem with each other so
for the l1 norm basically it's pretty
straightforward to see what the the sub
grading of the l1 norm is so if I write
here is that I mean what word it where
does it stop being visible okay well
good I'm gonna write here so the sub
differential of the l1 norm so let's say
that X is equal is not zero for I in
some set T and X I is equal to 0 for I
in the complement of t then the sub
differential is equal to let's say okay
well how about that V is in the sub
differential of this if VI is equal to
the sine of X I for I and T and VI is n
minus 1 1 for R and T times so basically
what it's saying is that so I have 1/2
so here what's a good example of a
function that is a max of affine
functions every convex function that's
terrible example terrible example my
singleton from that set no one L one
even but yeah I was a good one but even
better let's do the absolute value so
the absolute value of x is equal to the
max of X and minus X right so if it's
positive what achieves the maximum X and
then the vector there is just 1 so
that's what we have that's the singleton
set if it's negative you achieve - extra
cheese the maximum and in that case it's
minus 1 and at 0 they both achieve the
maximum so you take the convex hull 1
and minus 1
and that's exactly what we get make
sense Jim yeah and you get zero yeah
this only works for convex functions
sorry I apologize that's a great
question so sub differential theory if
your focus is not convex you could do it
but it's weird you have to do kind of a
partial sub differentiability because
you don't necessarily have sub
differentials you I mean we're really
the only way we're gonna get a fine
spaces to lie entirely under the
function if the function Kyle looks like
a bowl that's good that's the problem so
good clarifying question I should have
said that something for actual Theory
only applies to convex functions is it
useful we'll just we'll just say that's
true for the next hour and Terry
Rockefellers not here so I'm okay
I won't get in trouble Michael is here
all Michael called me on something funny
yesterday about about what was it part
of a lower semi continuity it's all
these things that I really wish I never
learned but anyway yeah there are
caveats that I'm slightly glossing over
that are technical but for most of the
applications that we're gonna look at
today especially these simple things
with L want I'm kind of just trying to
give as much too much details we need
okay so why do we care about sub grades
that's a good question so I think the
most useful fact about sub gradings I'm
gonna erase my terrible artwork that's
gone
so X minimizes F which is convex if and
only if zero is in the sub differential
of F at X I really don't want to call
this a theorem but might as well
microphone oh what we want to call that
it's very useful fact and I guess we
should call the fear at the theorem
because anything that follows
immediately from the definitions is
always up here so there you go so this
fall is immediately from the definitions
because with it if we take any other Z F
of Z is greater than or equal to F at X
I'm copying from right above here G
transpose Z minus X for any G that's in
the sub differential and that's zero so
f of Z is bigger than f of X so X
minimizes the function and vice-versa
clearly zero is in the sub u
differential if X minimizes the function
so light is good that's kind of what
it's like that's that's the sign that
your definitions are correct when your
important theorems are don't have to
improve anything okay so that's kind of
one of the motivations for where the sub
differential comes from more
interestingly and kind of what we're
going to need today in a theorem is X
minimizes F again compacts over ax
equals B
these evils because we don't confuse
ourselves if there exists a lambda such
that
a transpose lambda is in the sub
differential of FX + ax equals B one of
these funny things when I teach convex
optimization and we used to this is they
are called the KKT conditions for the
problem for actually it's like for this
problem where F is now the l1 norm I you
know I even do this but the students
always do this on the exam you always
forget to write down feasibility so
always forget to write so it's not
enough to just have the fact that you
have you have stationarity of the of the
cost so basically that you can't move in
the null space and we'll prove this in a
second it's fairly easy but the also
important things don't forget X has to
be feasible okay so the proof of this is
actually not not hard right so basically
and I can do it and then remaining space
on the board here if H is in the null
space of a then f of X would be plus h
right so this would be a feasible point
and that's going to be the only set of
feasible points are gonna be f of X plus
h we proved that already is greater than
or equal to f at x plus a transpose
lambda transpose H and now that's zero
a transpose lender was in the sub
differential the difference between f of
X plus h of X is H a times H is equal to
0 that's it okay so that's that's good I
mean again it's it looks trivial but
this this theorem is kind of a
foundation of almost all the proofs and
compress sensing this is what we're
gonna use take that in that's important
a transpose so what what I I'll just
write that up here we have a transpose
lambda transpose H which is equal to
lambda transpose a H and that H is in
the null space good question
okay so everybody with me so far any
questions about sub gradients or that
optimality condition this is going
considerably faster than I thought it
was going to so so I could take a pause
Michael said I'm supposed to pause after
half an hour and we're gonna have it
okay good
I mean the thing that's weird about it
is like these these definitions seemed
tautological and the proofs also seem so
trivial but it's in credit it's like
really powerful to get to the the proof
technique that we need this is the
theorem that we need so memorize that
for now so let us return to the problem
that we were studying at the beginning
we want to say one does X zero
all right so so here's the Rivera
strategy we know that X star will be the
minimum if we can satisfy well this will
be satisfied automatically all right I
mean we know that a of X 0 is equal to a
as X 0 good that's easy
we just need to satisfy this condition
so we need to find so we're proof oops
immutably
so we need to find lambda such that
let's say V is equal to a transpose
lambda V I is equal to the sine of X 0 I
if X 0 I is not 0 and V I and absolute
value is less than 1 if X 0 I is equal
to 0 okay this is what we want to
construct and most of these proofs are
at this is this is one way to actually
prove that these things work we're going
to construct a where this is called
Lagrangian struct of lambda that
certifies awesome Valley conditions
using a little bit of random matrix
Theory ok now let's let's define a
settee and Secada defined over there and
it's good to find again this is just
going to be the set of indices where X
is your I is not 0 this is sometimes
called the support when you go to read
these papers and we're gonna work we're
going to work with that support so what
we need is that a transpose lambda is on
the set T is equal to the vector e will
so have a vector E which is equal to the
sine of X 0 I on T so the vector E is
just gonna be a vector of signs it's
gonna be plus or minus once it will have
the length of vectors s and we want to
prove that a transpose lambda in L
infinity is less than 1 on the
complement
that's just saying that all the entries
are less at less than one an absolute
value right the L infinity norm says
that all the entries are less than one
and absolute value okay so this is this
what we're going to prove now the way
that these constructions almost always
go is we solve this equation equation EQ
and this is equation bound we solve EQ
just by using least squares so then
interestingly we use convex optimization
to construct our multiplier and a lot of
the more advanced algorithms use more
sophisticated algorithms than least
squares so for example there is a very
popular algorithm that was developed by
some folks to do quantum computing for
proving things about makers completion
this is kind of iterative construction
for constructing for approximately
solving this solution and they use
stochastic gradients to construct lambda
they approximately solve this using
stochastic grading so it's interesting
that you're use convex optimization to
solve this equation first we're gonna
use Lee squares and then you take the
solution you get out and you prove that
this holds with high probability ok so
the first thing to note is that as long
as M is this big this will have a
solution because a is random Gaussian
essentially means it's in general
position
so now let's approve so this will have a
solution a lot of the more sophisticated
techniques you even have to prove that
you could solve this but we can take it
for granted cuz we're using the Gaussian
ensemble gaussians make everything work
and easy Gaussian is always make your
life way too easy so what is the least
square solution of this equation
let's first partition the matrix a and I
will just assume that the first s
coordinates
I'm gonna prove strictly less than one
so one thing I am sweeping a little bit
under the rug here is that to get
uniqueness you need less strictly less
than one but let's let's say that what
we'll actually proved today is not that
it's a unique solution that's a solution
uniqueness requires just a little extra
I mean not much more and if I like to
speed I'm going I can actually show you
what we're missing to get uniqueness
yeah you need this happens way to get
uniqueness so I'm also going to rudely
assume that ATR the first T coordinate
so we can partition the matrix like this
so the T is just the first S coordinates
just permute the major so that's true
it's kind of like martin calls this
construction the dual witness and it's
kind of almost like we're we have
someone who is telling the idea would be
if someone told us where the support was
how could we certify that this solution
was true to someone who didn't know the
support so that's kind of the idea here
we're gonna we're gonna someone tells us
where it is we shuffle things so that
makes the proof look nice and then that
will guarantee that the solution works
out okay so we have 1880 compliment so
basically this guy is just saying that
80 now I've noticed a terrible problem
my notation how about how about will you
star for a joint you should have said
you're thinking that's okay write this
so from now on we will use the adjoint
as if we were over the complexes
fortunately we're over the reals so this
doesn't change anything so hey don't
worry about those boards are dumb those
are the past those are in the past man
what could erase that yes columns
columns so so basically this would be
like we'll have XT would be up here and
then XT compliment will be down here it
is this the part where we're not sparse
than the part where we are smooth
this guy no this the columns of a and
what we're gonna look at is a those
columns adjoint with lambda so lambda
lives in our m and a T is M by s so it's
over determined in particular but but so
that allows us to do the transpose this
way okay so what is the least square
solution of the sodium with sorry we got
a t star lambda equals e and actually
let me move to the next board we want to
minimize
now the transposes are completely in the
past erased from the record we want to
minimize nobody told me that I'm gonna
minimize in normal lambda subject to a t
transpose lambda is equal to e and I'm
going to just tell you the answer and
then exercise lambda is equal to 80
times 80 he inverse e it's the pseudo
inverse you can actually do this out
explicitly if you were to solve the KKT
conditions actually so the exactly the
proof that we had before find me I could
find me the solution the KKT conditions
you would just let's just square it so
we're really doing least squares and
then that thing that I just erased use
that that will prove that this is true
okay
and now you could also very readily
check for yourself that it works because
if I multiply through by a t-star
everything goes to the identity matrix
yes so so 8a is generated as random
Gaussian and it's kind of okay I'm using
something that is kind of obvious but
also not as immediately obvious is that
that that matrix is in general position
so any anything where I have more rows
and column will have a full rank will
have full row on column rank well no you
need something stronger for restricted
isometry really here we're just saying
general position I just need it
invertible I don't need anything I don't
need that this is actually well
conditioned that's something stronger
and I'm Martin are you going to talk
about restricted isometry these or very
briefly so what going on is auditioning
is a very solution right well
restricting the sama tree is just local
conditioning correct correct with the
fins correct and actually I think one of
the when you're doing something other
than gaussians you actually have to do a
little bit of work to prove that this is
actually invertible especially the
matrix Bernstein inequality is a really
simple way for a lot of random matrices
to prove that this system has a solution
that's why that's not why you would go
through all the trouble of dealing with
those large deviation inequalities for
us today because because it's just
Gaussian you just say well it's I mean
it satisfies no polynomial equations and
protect in particular those miners all
have to come it can't be zero
they can't vanish and so we just use the
property that we have this nice real
valued distribution the kind of just
sweep that under the rug is that hey of
course that's invertible yeah
wonderful that's a wonderful question so
this was this was the earliest I've seen
someone derive it derive no Rob you can
correct me on this the earliest I've
seen this particular on sots
this is this is a one of these standard
like this seems like a good idea and we
ran with it so this is who I guess is
what a nonsense is this ah sauce I think
because attributed to JJ Fuchs there's a
signal processing guy who's done a lot
of stuff on l1 and it's kind of at the
heart of what is essentially every
compressed sensing paper from 2004 to
2009 used an argument like this is this
the only way to do it I don't know but
it is a really interesting thing that
which is like even the more advanced
methods that's gumbo do you have it do
you have anything to add to that wat why
do we just do least squares
yeah yeah the over here right so how
could we do this it is a very weird
thing it's a very weird thing especially
in this case we're basically on the
we're trying it we're just trying to
what we'd really like is that that the
whole lambda that comes out we're a
transpose lambda it has small norm small
fitting norm this matrix one of the nice
things we're going to get this right now
if you look at this matrix these two sub
matrices in the Gaussian ensemble are in
completely independent they're
statistically independent of each other
so essentially what you want to do is
just fit this to be kind of as small as
we possibly can you do that by least
squares their product could be other
constructions it's convenient I guess
there's another thing that you might
want to say is like the first thing you
might try would be to do the more put
more penrose pseudoinverse and see what
happens
but there's no reason that isn't the
only way to do it and I'm sure that
they're yours I think a lot of stumbling
blocks certainly in the first matrix
completion paper that I wrote with a
manual one of the big stumbling blocks
which we just were trying to do this and
that ended up being 50 pages of a
nonsense that's crazy so it's really
like forcing it's like you know we had a
we have one idea and we're gonna force
that that that hammer to beat up on
everything
maybe so that could be the answer lack
of creativity that's pirates I wish I
had a better answer that pebble will
stick there for now how about that
any other questions well about this
construction
okay so we actually put that page down
let's get yeah go ahead RM RM so a has m
rows and s so 880 is M is 80 transpose
is gonna be s by M and then hopefully
yeah I've chased it you got to chase
dimensions too yeah
a is not but lambda will not be unique a
is not full rank oh sorry it's full full
row rank yeah but that doesn't
necessarily mean that you have a unique
dual solution I say in fact we
definitely don't have a unique dual
solution well this is a different we're
look this is different right this is a t
this is only the sub-matrix you think
yeah it's a good core is a great
question because it's a it's a
convenient construction actually so one
of the problems where this is actually
considerably easier to look at is when
you look at the lasso which is something
that we do in statistics so when we look
at the statistical problem actually in
that case the dual solution is unique
and so you can just write down the dual
solution and prove it has all the
properties you want and that's a that's
at the heart of some of Martin's work
improving that has the properties you
want it's not easy but still that it has
to be at least so you have a unique dual
solution here we have a lot of dual
solutions we have to pick one this is
the one we're going to pick I have
improved its dual feasible yet I've only
proven half of it so we satisfy DQ and
now we got a slant I bound let's let
roll with it for another we'll see where
it goes
okay so we satisfy DQ we got this out of
the way now the question is how do we
satisfy this dude okay so let's look at
that matrix what is that matrix this guy
will call Z is equal to a T complement
adjoin 80 80 80 verse e
we want to prove that the absolute value
of Zi are less than 1 for all I and D
this is called the remainder of the
proof or at least with high probability
over the ensemble there
how do we do that we do that so the
first thing and I mentioned this before
this matrix and this vector are
completely independent in the Gaussian
ensemble which makes the Gaussian the
sample could fit very easy to deal with
so what we might want to do is say what
is the norm of this guy if we condition
on the norm of this guy then this guy's
Z is just a Gaussian random variable and
then we're just pounding the magnitudes
of the Gaussian random variable that's
very easy to do right I mean we kind of
a tail that's where the Gaussian are
pretty easy okay so that's what we're
gonna do what do we think the norm of
this guy should be step one so well
let's call this vector alright have a
name for it it's called lambda her life
is good that vector has a name that's
called lambda so what is the normal what
do we think that normal lambda should be
all right so here is where we do we so
we're not gonna this would be another
place where random matrix theory would
often come in if we didn't have the
Gaussian but we're gonna use something
nice about gaussians and I'm going to
claim that that the norm of lambda
squared is distributed as s times M
times V 1 1 where B 1 1 is the
one one entry and and inverse Wishart
matrix with M degrees of freedom okay
what do I mean really complicated what
do I mean let's actually just write it
out what is lambda was the normal lambda
squared well you got a bunch of
cancellation the norm of lambda squared
is just equal to e transpose of a t a T
inverse times e matrix a lot of things
cancel okay so this is it this is just a
Wishart matrix which our matrix is just
the outer product of two gaussians okay
and we take its inverse and then we're
taking e transpose e the the nice thing
here is that the Gaussian ensemble is
okay again what are we using about the
Gaussian ensemble it's completely
isotropic it doesn't care what direction
the vector points in so this is a vector
of norm root s so I multiply this
through this is s times the first entry
is identically distributed s has the
first entry of b11 the M comes out
because we're assuming that a IJ just
distributed this way that's it so it's
Miss basically so now we just have to
control the large deviations of the
first entry of an inverse Wishard
conclave so here here is something that
is incredibly remarkable and it's
actually it's a very easy thing to prove
and maybe we'll do at the end if people
really want to see it but this is
identically distributed to an inverse
chi-square with M minus s plus 1 degrees
of freedom
as super cool very unexpected but I'd
like so so controlling the large
deviations of Chi squares it's easy
that's another thing that we could if we
had time we could just we could prove
the turnoff bound for that guy and I'm
like four lines and and that's all we
have to rely on that's the only large
deviations we need now why is that true
so basically the way that you would
prove that that's true is you would
write out the matrix inversion lemma for
what this guy looks like and you'll
quickly see that it's the projection of
an M dimensional vector onto a M minus s
plus one dimensional space everything's
go siient so everything remains Gaussian
and then you take a storm we can do that
out in detail but just trust me that's
that the proof is just what I said okay
so that's really the the hard part here
is just writing this in some convenient
way so what's the probability that the
norm of lambda squared exceeds let's say
a bound Tao what's the tail bound and
this one we were just going to copy from
or even better let me do it out so they
have a nice nice form for what we think
it should be together the chi-squared
and because we're normalizing we're
going to say what's the probability of
the norm of lambda exceeds m/s which is
that multiple that we got from here
divided by the degrees of freedom M
minus DT plus one and let's just take
our extra degree of freedom minus T is
less than or equal to X
or three called s s plus 1 minus G oh
sorry not happy with that alright so
this one is this is just a again
something that we're not going to derive
today there's a lot of references for
this one this is just the standard all
we're using is tell balance for the
chi-square distribution so yeah is yeah
so is M s times the inverse chi-square
yeah good and this this guy kind of is
just like you you could copy from like a
survey paper by mass are any book
registration inequalities it's kind of
one of the first ones you can do you
could derive it directly from the turn
off bound all right so any questions
about that because that's actually this
is the hardest part of the argument we
just have to control the norm of this
vector lambda and the way we do that is
in the case of the Gaussian ensemble I
mean that in all the proofs that you do
in compress sensing the first step you
have to do is compute the inverse and
then you have to control the bound you
could control the bound either by
controlling the norm of this matrix
which is typically what you do but we're
using the I socked repeat of the
Gaussian to control the whole vector at
once and when we did do some calculation
it turns out that we don't really need
anything particularly fancy we don't
need marchenko Bester we don't need
matrix Bernstein we just need to
understand how Chi squares work
questions about that guys are hanging in
there cuz we're uh we're almost done so
we could fill in all the gaps that I'm
skipping that's good let me erase it and
we'll finish the proof so the last step
is conditioned on the fact what is the
probability that the absolute value of
Zi exceeds 1 conditioned on the fact
that the normal lambda is less than that
what's the probability that one
component is too big well this is
exactly the same as the probability that
the magnitude let's call it W is greater
than one where W is normal and I want to
make sure I copy this right because the
M cancels with variance so is it like we
said basically once we condition on this
vector now we just have a Gaussian
matrix times a vector and hence we just
have a Gaussian random vector all we
have to know then is what the mean is
and what's the covariance the mean is
zero and it's actually just so now we're
looking at one component the mean and
the variance the variance is this
and so what's that bound what's that
equal equal because because I think it's
still fine right I think you're right so
if I say let's hurry we'll do though
you're right because it's an inequality
on the other constraint you're right
fine less they're equal to will take the
worst case all right and then we'll do
then this one this one don't need
anything fancy for either it's just the
probability that that's bigger than one
is just the minus one over two sorry
it's just the variance over - right even
the minds variance over -
okay so let's put it together and then
you can pester me so we want to say when
is x0 not the unique optimal when does
our thing fail when does our
construction fail we're going to upper
bound that by the probability of this
thing not actually being a good
multiplier so the probability that
lambda is not a good multiplier
it's just the probability that a top T
compliment lambda infinity is bigger
than 1 this is less than or equal to n
minus s times X of minus M minus s plus
1 minus t over 2 F so if the probability
of the this conditional expectation not
being true plus the probability of the
of the thing that we're conditioning on
not being true which is X minus T
squared over 4 m minus s plus 1
close parentheses okay so this is the
probability that our construction
doesn't work again it's the probability
that conditioned on lambda having well
behaved norm we have a deviation in the
size of these vz-- ice plus the
probability that lambda fails the thing
that worked the condition that we're
conditioning on is these two bounds I
claim that if you plug in T and I don't
want to do this so we're not going to do
it DT plus one ice epsilon s log and
square root of 1 minus 2 s epsilon over
1 plus epsilon minus 1 this proves the
theorem
so the probability of failure this guy
is basically achieved by plugging in
this value of T how we get that value of
T we set these two these two terms equal
to each other I don't know we can do
something else and that will give us
this expression okay so that that's
that's the proof so let's step back and
go through what what did we what do what
were the steps the first one was
understand basically what our good with
no knowledge what makes a good
certificate that we have the right
answer what are the combinations we need
we needed just basically this this dual
solution we need something to satisfy
the KKT conditions to satisfy them we
wrote down the KKT conditions we got
equality constraints and inequality
constraints we plugged in our equality
constraints check those off life was
good and then we proved the inequality
constraints by basically just satisfying
this with least squares to prove the
inequality constraints we were in this
so there are two things that are
difficult for general compressed sensing
problems one if this is not Gaussian you
have to do some work to actually prove
that the least squares solution exists
for that you typically have to use a
matrix Bernstein equality when you use
gaussians when you have the Gaussian
design that just happens because the
Gaussian is in general position second
thing we had to proof was that these
deviations are not the the infinite
deviations were not big to do that we
had we just use two facts which we could
go through if you care one is that the
that basically the norm of lambda has
this very nice inverse chi-squared
distribution and so that makes most of
our life easy and then the second fact
is just using properties of the Gaussian
the second fact is very easy and that
gives us and that that proves our kind
of fundamental compressed sensing
theorem good yet quit yes
okay Thomas tell me yeah
because what's happening is each entry
is an ocean or with length lambda square
yes I like that good so we do the proof
so wonder do we lovely okay there we go
so that's a great okay so remember the
question before is why are we picking
this lambda why this solution well when
we go through the proof we just need
lambda to be small so I'm gonna pick the
least squares one we want the normal
lambda to be small I'm gonna pick the
one with smallest normal that's nice
that only works in the Gaussian case but
again that's fine that works well in the
gaussian case actually you will see this
again if you look at these more
complicated arguments typically you do
have to control the norm of lambda
square that's actually the thing that
you're always controlling because that's
gonna kind of it kind of propagates in
to this matrix even when these are
dependent you still kind of you try to
decoupled these two things and then just
bow the norm of this side yeah correct
and in any of it what's like what
they're what you would do is you now
control the singer values of this matrix
and then just let this guy have root s
the problem there is now you have this
awful root s that kicks around and this
is why whenever you see an argument that
says we assumed the signs are random
what that is doing is trying to use an
extra lifting inequality to basically
get rid of that root S it's cheating
that's alright we prove things that we
can prove right so that's but that's
that's really we're the hook being equal
why they always say we assume a random
sign pattern is really just because we
don't you know you you're considering
you can't you don't have the I saw
through P that you have in the Gaussian
case
yeah yes say anything that's near the s
barse has larger l1 or much more right
and I get that what that typically would
be one thing that's close to to that
kind of characterization is you would
say that if I you want to say that no
vectors which are maybe 2's or 3s bars
lie in the null space of a and that
would also kind of give you a similar
characterization and that is another
that is another somewhat awkward thought
in a way of proving this and that's kind
of related to these Cohen's is what you
try to say is that the in the null space
of a there are no good there are no
sparse vectors or there are no vectors
with reasonable l1 norm these are called
null space conditions and these are
closer to the kind of picture I drew at
the beginning where we try to basically
bound things away from this cones there
are there are a lot of different
properties of the that what can we say
about the null space I mean so let's see
Martin how much of that are you gonna
talk about
I can either punter I can just know I
can just talk yeah
we go down the width of the null-space I
think that's kind of what you end up
doing so what you what you want to look
at is you want to look at the you will
look at the set of so we have the
knowledge a intersected with the set of
sparse factors and so what you can do in
those cases is use so there are a
variety of ways that actually I think
the the one I like the most is by roots
inversion and they can actually down the
norm of these sparse vectors on the null
space of a they use something called
Gordon's theorem which is basically just
this Gaussian concentration inequality
with another thing that we can do if you
are after your sports factors you can
look at the set up this cone idea and
look at basically how what is the norm
of a times V min where V lives in the
tangent cone it has norm 1 all right so
this is like a restricted singular value
and you can also bound this you can also
found it these times actually what's
nice about this is if you use Gordon's
argument what you get is something that
looks like square root of M minus the
Gaussian complexity of the cone I would
forget how to write a script G of the
cone the Gaussian complexity or the mean
width or proportional to the mean width
of a cone so that it what's really neat
about that is it's kind of tying into
ideas that we use in statistical
learning theory we're really just
talking about something which is the
kind of this this natural complexity
measure and that actually just comes in
here so in the case that you use the
entire space let's say we have an
estimation of space this is the
Marchenko pester lower bound on the
singular value if you restrict it to
just a comb you get a different answer
and that actually that will give you
this bound the one I really wanted for
sparse vectors this will prove that the
number of measurements is 2 times 1 plus
epsilon s log n over s I think plus 5
the quarters s we have an argument for
for this I think the paper to look at
there is by Chandrasekar on 100 s sake
are too many letters
Pirela will see we have kind of a we
actually have a big diatribe and I said
kind of what I wanted to close but we
have a big diatribe about how you make
this more general so this was looking at
the l1 norm but really the argument goes
much more general we have any function
here which somehow is suggesting low
complexity we can really characterized
in terms of basically the width of the
dissent cone how many measurements are
required to reconstruct the particular
object you're looking for and you get
what's nice is that the argument because
it's using Gaussian complexities you can
get very very tight bounds we use that
we have a little trick to the test make
the Gaussian complexity of cones that
tends to be a somewhat simple object to
to estimate so that's a but that that's
an advertisement for 4.com where this
goes another place where this goes you
have approximately sparse you can do
these can be noisy and you kind of build
upon most of these ideas and so that
Martin when he talks about the Hydra my
school statistics will use a lot of the
ideas a lot of the similar kind of
duality ideas to kind of build up those
constructions this simple argument that
I was talking about actually does extend
to this the one we did today extends to
a couple other norms so basically
extends to anything which is a key
component or decomposable norms was
something that was invented but actually
I don't know who to attribute this to of
Martin who invented decomposability this
Ahad this notion of one enormous
decomposable allegedly huh
there's a collective thing so it's a
berkeley idea there you have the idea
that basically we had an equation which
i erased which was you had that eighty
so a star lambda on once that T was
equal to some vector e and the norm of a
star T sub lambda put another star here
is less than one on some other space
there are many norms where basically the
optimality conditions break down to
something like this where you want to
find a solution of a least squares
problem and then bound some norm so I
put a little star here some random norm
on the orthogonal space to this this
vector these these norms are just
generally called decomposable they
consist of the l1 norm the ones I know
the l1 norm the sum of L 2 norms sort of
have block-by-block sparse vector and
also the nuclear norm all have this
property and in all those cases in the
paper by Candice and myself we actually
that's where this argument is spelled
out it's in mathematical programming in
2012 and we actually go and analyze
those things and you get very nice tight
bounds again just using this argument
the thing that's nice is the only part
of the argument that changes as we
change norms if you have this
decomposable property is this last one
because you just wish our thing holds
generically because you're always
solving this least squares thing so that
thing holds generically and then all you
have to do is understand how to bound
these norms in different ways depending
on how the norm changes any other
questions yeah
that's very smart
so though well again the idea is that
what you what you do is you use all the
techniques I know do the following you
open up a convex analysis book and you
say what certifies optimality question
one and there are like there are only a
few things you have KKT conditions we
have the null-space condition I'm what I
guess there actually are there like
these other weird constraint
qualifications we can go like the mega
seryan problem with something rather and
you can go find that you write down
those equations they will have a random
matrix in them and then you certify that
that random matrix actually satisfies in
equations that is the procedure that's
right I mean this is this is mathematics
right I hope we don't necessarily yet
have a way to make this exact weot I
don't know if we necessarily have a
crank that get generates for this yet
but that might be a nice fun thing to
work on this semester
the best wait so I think that we're
still on that in that situation I think
it's a another place where we're still
in that situation is in and it's very
related actually is in minimax theory
where we'd like to prove lower bounds on
what was actually doable in that same
case we have we have a general argument
there's a couple of general arguments
whether they be using fans inequality
using kind of the worst what I was
called a least favorable prior using
hypercute constructions but it's still
not the point yet where I can feed it to
a computer and they can spit out the
proof yet yeah right I think that's also
good that's a good argument what we what
you really want is something that sits
deeply inside this constraint so you
have to satisfy this constraint exactly
and then you want to construct a lambda
that says click this and inside this as
possible inside this code you know you
have it the other you have an infinite
set you have the big sub differential
you want you actually this is kind of
interesting I've never thought about
this before but but often the case when
you look at sub gradient analysis when
you actually look at optimization
algorithms the the most preferable sub
green is that at least norm because that
actually is the one that's guaranteeing
you that you're going downhill so it
does seem to be that's something that
occurs a lot that the least norm sub
gradient is almost like a gradient and
has this kind of the most stable one
what
yeah so the only thing else that I'm not
gonna you know I actually think that
most people should go get coffee and if
anybody really wants to see why this is
distributed as an inverse-square you can
hang out